well I watched fallers I've watched
every series come always ours to ballers
to everything itself I like ballers I'm
new to that go through the Studios can
open up soon so we get new [ __ ] I don't
know man that's a big issue isn't it
then the Hollywood is really really
panicking because they just don't know
how to do this and I think Netflix is
running out of content and and well
that's obvious you know and sip through
it so I don't know man
we are living in an unprecedented times
2002 that's a dozen 20 can eat my dick
and it all started with me blowing that
a sec death whistle and I want to
apologize to everybody did well hold on
did was it Nasdaq whistle or was it Kobe
dying first I think I blew the Aztec
whistle and two weeks later the epidemic
hit so I think Kobe had already passed
I'm not sure it started with Kobe though
I think Kobe set it off then you blow
that whistle definitely helps it didn't
help death no that was probably really
dumb I got a a joke I believe Joe cuz he
started blowing at first he wasn't doing
it properly
no problem as I did it very well and he
got his lips around it really you just
might buy Mike ovid free lungs back then
and this is just a silly video of
recreating what their daughters were
doing trying to take like Instagram kind
of doggy photos I'm so mad I didn't do
this oh my god that's so good
he's so good humor humor is the best
looks like your dad at a grandpa though
you know maybe so Brennan you mentioned
this before how it Shia LaBeouf actually
got chest tattoos yep so we finally got
to see it the artist shows
what do you did exactly so check this
out yeah that's that's better like
they're all real apparently that's what
the artist is saying and everyone else
is like this is not committed to the
role he was it says here across his
stomach that's his character's name
creepers yeah
promise it then then you're not doing
the movie anymore so what do we do from
there what I do know if the tattoo
represented something with his family to
his mom and stuff like that then cool
tattoo good work yeah really cool okay
you know it doesn't help let me just say
this about [ __ ] when you're sick I
just want to let me just say this to
anybody who has a friend who said don't
do the two things number one don't give
me advice on what to do cuz you're not a
doctor so whatever you do
III get like like Joseph Joseph anymore
I love so much doctor is he he goes you
know bro do um do miss a general list as
he goes do large doses they say do large
doses of what is a so far it sounds like
you've really got a lot of research on
that [ __ ] thing and everybody's got a
different point of view take all the
zinc take all the vitamin D take all the
vitamin C get a neti pot it'll be gone
in two days
shut the [ __ ] up none of you were
doctors then I talk to doctors and they
go gotta let it run its course or maybe
my hydrochloric one or maybe inhalable
steroids or nothing or [ __ ] maybe
nothing because you can talk I will try
to me what without our other friend now
that they found out we have coded me a
friend see you send me and Brian
negative [ __ ] about Kovac oh that's when
I'm stick please don't send me articles
about how some people never come out of
it and have organ damage for the rest of
their lives and brain image please don't
do that mom mom don't tell me that my
tastes may never come back mom and other
family members and friends who who cut
Astro Phi's I'm already feeling like
[ __ ] I don't need you adding to my
anxiety about how this I can be the one
rare case that never gets better or gets
worse and dies if you don't mind
[ __ ] I don't like negative [ __ ] and
now that I have it the people are saying
you can get it twice and they're getting
they're sending me all this stuff about
that I don't need you that either I
don't need this whole pin okay I get it
that life sucks this will make the whole
Crona stuff and just the whole terminal
until 2020 a lot of people that we
associated with have shown their true
colors and I like you know what I can't
be friends with you anymore
we won't talk once the world goes back
to normal we just we won't talk anymore
probably not no I wanna master Kim rates
t-shirt okay you can try and I don't
give a [ __ ] hey you know I'm the new
pop-up when I see you and you're Kovac
free I'm gonna take that that
lizard-skin
this I don't have your your whatever
your cameras do it
I got beautiful I'm gonna take it and
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] make you
wear a human mass hey you know in
Afghanistan when the normal I'm gonna
make it like like a uncircumcised dick
I'm do that to your face like this well
they used to take they would take when
they capture you in Afghanistan they
would cut your cut all the way around
your waistband and then take that skin
and pull it up over your head and tie it
so you'd be in your own skin bag you
making this up no I'm not no one a long
time I was taking that extra lizard
iguana skin you got there and give me a
[ __ ] circumcision I don't have any
kind of skin dude I have tight skin I
don't know what your camera's doing here
who the [ __ ] is laughing what else you
guys got it's really hard to change
minds that's why I always like to tip my
hat to the true feminists which are the
women of the USA and the USC and then
away
I'm telling you historically nobody's
talking about this and you and I have
talked about it but like if you want to
talk about the forefront of LGBTQ you
want to talk about feminism women like a
man in núñez rose
miss yuan Tian Jin jack Valentina Cinco
these women who stepped into a cage and
showed men in different countries
including places like Dagestan Russia
that aren't as progressive that women
can do this to you know that does change
minds it does it changes hearts and
minds and so if you're talking about
actually persuading and changing the
world and getting men to see women in a
more egalitarian light you would be
hard-pressed to find a better example
than the women of MMA and I'm serious
and nobody talks about it you would be
so hard to question and let's just talk
a little bit about a man and unions
who's a woman whose girlfriend correct
me if I'm wrong is for the quantum she's
a fighter though - she's a fighter
that [ __ ] is that's that's being seen by
people from countries that don't have a
very liberal view of lgt like all of
Brazil Brazil are not that friendly
towards the the gay community these are
very conservative places but it's hard
to deny human excellence human beauty
and human potential when you see someone
like Amanda Nunez who is gay and that
[ __ ] incredible fighter think of Gina
Carano man you know everyone forgets
about Jenny crap hold up you talking
about the straight-up supermodel who was
a world champion kickboxer and she
looked like that and then also hungry
fights cyborg well don't forget about
Rhonda whose basic voice Gracie of your
right Gina Khurana was the first one who
you can you talk about a straight movie
star who also happen to be a world
champion kickboxer and her gang Otto and
her dad played in the NFL - yes and and
one thing to keep in mind also is that
these women didn't do it by drawing
differences between men and women or
writing books or critical books of man
but what they did was they they they
through their actions they showed us how
similar we are and the problem in
identity politics is it draws
distinctions between groups and what we
should be doing is focusing on the
commonality between all of us and one of
the things that's great about I'm a
comedy whatever it might be is that you
either can punch people are you gonna
knock somebody out or make somebody
laugh or you can't nobody gives a [ __ ]
about what color you are if you're good
you're skill you're good at your skill
and it brings us all together and what
happens is everybody moving for that one
person people are cheering for a man
[ __ ] about where sexuality is no care
where she's from they're just cheering
for an excellent human being yeah yeah
and it's important to keep in mind
that's the strength of of accomplishment
and a meritocracy
that's where politics in and this this
weird identity politics is really a
problem it Dave it highlights the
differences and tries to separate people
it doesn't bring it doesn't it doesn't
focus on you coming out my back rebel
and I pull myself up like a champ like a
champ through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a Gish and it's a
gift
it's a gift